maurice with an interview with michelle
inasco of the monsanto fund i believe
it's insco
of the monsanto fund uh welcome to the
show thank you i know you guys
will be back my pleasure indeed you know
you i know you guys keep doing a lot of
great work in the communities tell us
about your work here in st louis
sure so monsanto fund which actually
officially
uh we are now a part of bayer of
tomorrow is our day one
so just to adjust we're required uh but
monstantial fund um
as an entity continues for now and um
we have been working to improve lives in
communities where monsanto employees
live and work
since 1964. here in st louis
we fund primarily programs in food and
nutrition
stem education and then some community
developments
programs such as after school programs
and summer
programming so that seems to dovetail
nicely with chess
tell us why you guys are involved in
chess it does so we've been supporting
um the chess program here in st
louis for four years we give about
twenty five thousand dollars a year
to get chess into the classroom the
reason we support chess
is stem education science technology
engineering and math is obviously
important to us
and chess brings those stem skills
specifically math skills
to students but it also helps with some
of the softer skills that kids might not
necessarily
learn in the classroom things like
critical thinking strategy
problem solving so we love to support
this chess program because
the students get it a little bit twofold
they get those stem skills but then they
get those other
skills that will make them successful
employees as they get older
so how are we going to get you to give
50 000
[Laughter]
well we'll see since uh you know we are
a new company and we will have new
budgets
you know there we go exactly
exactly but we um we're aiming to be in
45
um st louis public schools this year i
think there's a total of 75
in the district so we're working on it
so we've been you know trying to grow
the program and
um really important for us just to get
that chess into the school
day so many schools have after school
programs or clubs
and that's great for the kids who have
parents who will sign them up
for those programs having it during the
school day means that every child
is exposed to it and that's important to
us because
a child does not know that they love
chess until they actually play
so do you please yours i don't my kids
do though
your kids okay we'll forgive you on that
exactly i play on the app
a little bit yours
i need to i need to learn there you go
marissa ashley teaches chess
uh you have you been following this
event at all you know you know some of
the best players in the world come to
play in the event do you ever
take a gander in and say i'm rooting for
so-and-so so i don't follow that closely
um but when you have the big tournaments
like this
in town um the whole community knows and
hears about it i mean just
walking outside of chess club um
it's much more active out there during
these weeks than it normally is
which is so fantastic for the community
so
we appreciate that and we love when you
do host these tournaments because it
brings
so much more exposure to chess so do
your do you or your kids have a favorite
player
no i don't think so i don't i mean i'm
going to have to learn so when i'm back
next year i'm going to tell you who my
favorite
fabiano caruana should be the answer to
that question very quickly
there we go he's going for the world
championship thank you so much for all
the work that you're doing
on all the uh money that you put into
the community and i'm going for that
hundred thousand
okay well it's been a hundred so far
because we're four years in well
i'm going for the there you go you want
the annual yeah that's right
we can certainly use it okay great work
thank you very much thank you appreciate
it
thank you